es interesante que josep borrell ha
dicho que ha sido una conversación
franca y sincera lo cual en lenguaje
diplomático significa que han discutido
abiertamente sobre la represión a los
disidentes en rusia pero no está
dispuesta a recibir sermones ni
lecciones de occidente así que es poco
probable que cualquier presión que haya
ejercido hoy
la situación penal que está abocado a
pasar dos años y medio
ha insistido en criticar los estándares
la policía también en países
occidentales durante los últimos días de
nuestras fuentes del gobierno ruso se
han esforzado en mandar un mensaje claro
a la unión europea ya estados unidos es
ahora dicen de que se ocupen de sus
propios asuntos